[Musik]
bisher haben wir nun von österreich vor
den österreichischen markt forster
besucht und dort das leckere
kürbiskernöl probiert wir nehmen kann
simon wieso knoblauch blöden bei
ehrlichen priska gegessen
am adlerhof die hühner gefüttert und
beim biohof tomic vieles über soja
erfahren
jetzt geht es weiter nach wien dort
findet nämlich beim interspar die
autogrammstunde statt
[Musik]
letzte mal im humor eleven zur
signierstunde da unten warten jetzt
schon ganz viele der linken muss
zwingend alle zurück außerdem
heruntergelassen wenig warten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im deutschsprachigen raum
[Musik]
jetzt wendet sich nicht schon vorbei
insgesamt dreieinhalb stunden ich werde
mir ganz genau wie geschäfte dahinter
spaß bot truck und wir holen wir uns
hinten stärkung
[Musik]
was man gern wenn man in österreich
treffen sie mit musik und vielen dank
[Musik]
aber das müssen wir probieren das gewürz
öl das ist der wahnsinn
[Musik]
yamanaka hammer und die frau die dich
mal heiratet mein lieber scholli
[Musik]
wenn wir in wien ist dann muss man auf
jeden fall zum prater jetzt auf dem
vater unterwegs mal schauen was es hier
alles gibt unser erforscht ob ist direkt
hier wir sind der nase nachgegangen und
gehen jetzt mal ins schokoladenmuseum
sie steht schon die kakaobohne
anni ist kommt später zu der tafel
schokolade und pralinen später charlie
später ist dm und m
[Musik]
sind die lecker
komm wir gehen zur echten schachtel
hartz iv ich glaube ich mache ein
workshop heute hier gerade im
museumsbereich den schauen wir uns
später noch mal an
jetzt gehen wir erstmal direkt in den
workshops und schokolade machen
nicht so groß
[Musik]
tommy
geröstete phase los geröstete
kaffeebohnen in dunkler schokolade
das wird meine worte oh mein gott
hier sieht man jetzt grade kakaobohnen
event frisch geröstet es doch das so
lecker im paradies sind wir wissen mit
der sorte und die vierte kind ich meine
zwei tafeln mit zartbitterschokolade und
eine mit vollmilch für die kids und
jetzt wird es hier ein gegossen und dann
kommen die zutaten rein
dann hier drauf die luftbläschen
verschwinden lassen das wird jetzt wie
auch im powerplay für samira und emma
[Musik]
ich liebe schokolade mit ganzen müssen
wir machen jetzt das allererste rezept
das sie mit schokolade gegeben hat ja
mit kakaopulver geröstet und gemahlen
und übersetzt hieß das getränk dann das
bitter weil cacau einfach ein bisschen
bitter schmeckt und das haben die frauen
zu hause zubereitet mit diesem
schlagstock für die männer dann machen
wir kein ungemein hatte gesagt bin ich
mal gespannt also ein gutes fitness
getränk jetzt machen unsere 15 minuten
sport einleiten
kein problem es war anstrengend sein
sport gemacht und trinken jetzt noch
dieses getränk nach schlanken
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt
es riecht fantastisch
leicht bitter
juli merklich nicht stimmt kommt ganz
leicht durch also richtig lecker man
kann es natürlich noch zucker dazugeben
aber in milch schmeckt so schon mal sehr
gut wenn ich schon keine cinderella
schon vom staat bekommen es ist eben ein
auto geladen
[Musik]
jetzt für schokolade fertig und wir
können sie aus der form stürzen bisschen
festhalten denn die schokolade fällt
wenn sie gut temperiert ist von ganz
alleine aus perfekt
[Musik]
passagieren der schokoladenfabrik was
ich super interessant wir fragen jetzt
gerade unsere schokoladen war es noch
ein und machen wir noch ein bisschen was
und dann gehen wir raus zum vater war
echt super und ich werde auf jeden fall
mal wir versprochen ein schokoladen
video für euch drehen
schutzkleidung an und los geht's
[Musik]
man ist bei euch ist der joghurt ganz
besonders denn machte er selber ja als
ich kenne es von meiner mama so die
macht zu hause auch joghurt und lässt
einfach die milch aufkochen wieder
abholen steckt den kleinen finger rein
und dann sagt sie wenn er dann schön
warm ist dann kommt der joghurt ration
wird gezüchtet ist es für euch
wir verbinden regionale liegt aber jetzt
kommt von einem ganzen polen büro des
fünf kilometer richtung dann sind es die
system ist am meer jetzt aufgeheizt und
vor allem wesley ist bild super oder
nicht er dann wieder abgekühlt und hier
in wir verwenden ganz traditionelle
jugendkulturen gebrauchten fürs
fermentieren für die 24 stunden und dann
noch 24 stunden kühlung und dann kommt
das heraus das entrée [ __ ] joghurt
ganz tolles aroma liebe säure und das
ist die basis für
als ich darf jetzt nicht sagen dass er
besser ist als der von meiner mama weil
sie dann wahrscheinlich sauer wird aber
er ist besser und dann macht ihr den
joghurt nehmen denn als basis und dann
gibt es ganz viele verschiedene maria
gallo genau
also ich gehe einfach mal der name von
hinten wird nicht gerade eingetroffen
und wird maracuja joghurt hergestellt
und den römerberg mal zusammen
[Musik]
sie entsteht ist bereit sofort also
nicht richtig die maracuja das grab
eines opfers gerufen
schlag auf schlag
man sieht so wie man es zu hause auch
fehler machen würde
[Musik]
auch hier sieht man die handarbeit beim
85 wird alles per hand zubereitet und
natürlich auch per hand abgefüllt eine
richtige wohnung faktur eben
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt auf ist nach vom ram
man war immer die exakt gleiche menge
drin
[Musik]
lieber jetzt ramon milch reis
hergestellt der wind reißt es schon
vorbereitet dann habt ihr auch ihr
selber klicken und dann kommt noch dazu
was kommt noch dazu ist viel zu viel
emotion youtube die wir auch selber
machen die schokolade drin
dann müssen wir dann unbedingt probieren
was mich total fasziniert ist das
wirklich ohne konservierungsstoffe
verarbeitet wird ohne aromastoffe
farbstoffe sind heute zubereitet und
abgezockt worden direkt schon wenn die
interspa regale und ist ab dann sieben
tage haltbar
ohne künstliche zusätze wirklich sehr
frisch sehr regional und natürlich
lokale
[Musik]
so kommt jetzt sozusagen unter anderem
der boden milchpreise weiße schokolade
zum intersport als ich habe bis jetzt
gesehen die manufaktur sich diese
handarbeit was mich interessiert ist wie
kommst du denn überhaupt auf die idee
wie lange gibt es den betrieb schon und
machte einfach der auslösende grund wir
sind ein ganz junges unternehmen drei
jahre
ich bin kunde ausbildung zu
lebensmitteltechnologie produktion ein
bisschen auf der hand gelegen soviel ich
weiß und alles und das sind motivierter
das ich gesehen habe dass der fokus
richtet auch immer mehr richtung
künstlichkeit gebe supermarkt und ich
habe mir gedacht gerade bei diesen
produkten geht das anders auch junge
designer für die fürsten und da kann man
wirklich die natürlich heißen lasst noch
die zeit sprechen lassen wie das
versucht die wir wirklich super lecker
ist davon gelesen muss mit zum probieren
herzlichen sagen danke das war's an dass
wir ihnen alles gute
[Musik]
gerade waren wir auch in der stadt die
zimmer ein kleines stückchen gefahren
und hier mitten in wien gibt einen bio
feigen hof also ihr seht genau richtig
dass hinter mir sind ganz viele
feigenbäume hier gibt's den bio feigen
bouffier werden zeigen natürlich
geerntete gibt es ab mai ist richtig
leckere gewürze kräuter und ich besuche
heute ist harald und sogar denn die
betreiben hier diesen hof seit vielen
vielen jahren und sie wohnen sogar hier
[Musik]
neben harald und ursula ihr beiden ihr
leitet er den feigen hof ihr seid die
inhaber erst ganze gegründet und ihr
wohnt auch hier
wir hatten das alles angefangen ja das
war unsere idee so vor zwölf jahren
wollten wir ein gemeinsames projekt
starten
hier hat der haare schon eben einfach
grundstück der gemeinde linie habt es
waren hier uralte glashaus hatte man
nicht mehr heizen konnte weil wir
befinden uns hier im wiener
gemüseanbaugebiet und so sind wir auf
die kultur der feige zunächst gekommen
dass die feige unser hauptprodukt und
unser mutiges produkt weil wir selber
nicht wussten war ob es funktioniert ich
kenne die frage aus der türkei meine
eltern sind von dort und im urlaub habe
ich die immer vom baum gepflückt und
gegessen
ich kenne auch aus unserer region aber
nicht diese vollen großen früchte also
sage ich noch nie gesehen
er hat früher schon in einem glas hause
in beiden bomben also gezogen und auch
davon ernten können
und da war er sich sicher dass auch die
fein kultur funktioniert wir sammeln
spezial zu orten die so - 15 -20 grad
aushalten und wie er nur ganz reife
früchte so dass ihr wirklich auch das
gefühl haben wie bei dir zu hause und
das sehr schön vermietung zu können hier
in wien in niederösterreich und das wie
reife früchte bekommen ja nicht sind wir
euch hier auf den feigen mord kommt ist
ein ganz besonderes erlebnis man sieht
schon wie ihr das ganze auch lebt und
hier bekommt man eure produkte aber
allerdings eben auch am ender spar
interspar führt also eine ganz spezielle
abteilung also regionale betriebe bauern
die sehr ehrenwert also produzieren das
praktisch diese produkte also nicht nur
regional zu bekommen sind sondern doch
vielleicht auch ein bisschen weiter weg
am anderen ende von wien des 19
mitten in der stadt hat produziert ja
sehr viele sachen im glas ist er ab ins
glas die feigen mit zehn kilo zucker so
ganz ganz wenig zucker nur und wir haben
viele bekannte noten wie mit pinien
rossmann und
es gibt anzeigen senf oder auch ein
chutney und wir essen diese produkte
auch zu käse amt die paste feige chor
kann aber das vorstand sein malader er
oder das ist eine marmelade ja aber wir
machen zu sagen wie schön ich konnte
also frei gebuhr ist das basisprodukt
eben mit diesem feigen ganz wenig zucker
aber auch seine bio orangen öle bio
zitronenöl ein bisschen charta und und
ein hauch zimt erforschen und parkhäuser
gesehen ich glaube wir können es
vielleicht hinten noch ein bisschen ruhe
anschauen
ist hier eigentlich wie viele kräuter
ihr habt 100 oder 300
[Musik]
sicher gibt es auch lavendel am zucker
oder einfach die blüten nur dekoration
zu ehren oder im kleiderschrank
[Musik]
das ist ein paradies gibt's weiße
auberginen
[Musik]
also jetzt wahrscheinlich hier
angefangen mit feigen maloja bio feigen
wurf und ich sehe auch er feigenbäume
haben ganz viele bäume wir haben 150
fällen certain gesammelt und hier ganz
viele bäume gepflanzt und das was uns im
freiland 150 seiten 150 sorten wir
gesammelt mittlerweile ich glaube als
normalsterblicher weiß man gar nicht wie
viele sorten es überhaupt gibt also
feigenbaum war für mich einfach so ein
feigenbaum kann man da wenn man sich
jetzt selber zu hause und feigenbaum
einpflanzen wir was falsch machen ja
schon also ganz schlecht beim beim
aussuchen der sorte ist es dass meine
sorte auswählt die partien okapis das
heißt die ohne bestäubung früchte bildet
packen wenn man sich aus der türkei oder
griechenland einen baum mitnimmt oder
wenn man ihn durch samen vermehrten dann
hat man mit größter wahrscheinlichkeit
eine pflanze die im nicht patino gratis
das heißt sie macht dann schon früchte
irgendwann nach längerer zeit aber die
früchte fallen ab die vor die pflanze
reife das bevor mal klappt morgen ist
die reifen die früchte und das ist
eigentlich sehr schade dann natürlich
nur eine eigentlich meine tier konnte ja
und ich sehe schon ganz viele feigen
auch ganz viele früchte aber ist jetzt
nicht erst rein
die sind noch nicht reif diese filme
sind in ca ja ich würde mal sagen in 14
tagen drei tage später kommuniziert arge
jahre also unsere mitte juni beginnt er
jetzt ist die frage noch nicht drehen
man sieht dass daran dass sie so im
rechten winkel vom ast weg steht
wenn dann die frage registern ist nicht
nur die felge welt sondern auch das
spielfeld
und dann hängt die frucht runter also
wenn sie runter hängt dann ist geheim
also wenn aus dieser austria aus diesem
lockten honig hoffmann raus kommt dann
ist die frucht überreif aber das
schmeckt sie ganztags am besten wenn man
noch keine sie ganzes jahr
und wenn man noch beachtet dann hat man
halt geholt das war bei den affen die
die überreifen vergorenen früchte essen
und dann bombardiert
[Musik]
doch ganz exotische sachen wie zum
beispiel diese indianer banane die wird
erst im september geerntet und schmeckt
anscheinend inzwischen banane und mango
also eine ganz exotische frucht und ich
bin hier den ausblick so genial
hier haben wir das ganze grün und da
hinten einfach die stadt also wir sehen
wirklich wir sind mitten in wien und ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass ich hier mitten
in wien so was entdecke so ein paradies
ein grünes und lecker
[Musik]
also ich mache jetzt auch bald im garten
bei uns zu hause und ich will einen
feigenbaum pflanzen und natürlich auch
zeigen was muss ich denn beachten
ja also es gibt zwei möglichkeiten wenn
man in seinem garten oder zu hause
bewegen haben möchte die erste
möglichkeit ist es einen baum auf die
terrasse zu stellen wenn man keinen
garten haben wir machen einen garten
hautnah braucht man einen sonnigen platz
und ja das gibt es auch wieder zwei
varianten man kann ein baum hinstellen
also mit einem stamm oder einen strauch
hinstellen oder strauch wird etwas
breiter der frauen wird höher da kann
man dann unter dem bäumchen seinen
kaffee trinken wichtig ist viel sonne
wichtig ist viel gießen im sommer und
wichtig ist auch eine möglichst kalte
aber frost vorher überwinterung manche
lassen den baum auch draußen stehen
packen ihn ein
aber wenn ein sehr langer kalter winter
es kann das vielleicht das problem sein
dass er besser ist es ihm kalt draußen
frei zu werden
ok also einem kühlen keller oder in der
garage herrsche gar kein problem aber im
garten habe ich ja die problematik nicht
weil da ist er in der erde genau wärmer
geld genau im garten wieder sonniger
platz relativ viel platz und raum wird
ziemlich große klar unsere kleineren
sollten werden so drei meter groß und
die nach 15 jahren ja und die größeren
werden können auch etwas größer werden
eventuell ist es gut den baum vor einer
mauer zu pflanzen also wenn man die
möglichkeit hat vor einer ostmauer oder
für einer südmauer den baum pflanzen
nach dieser abstand halten und dann hat
einerseits damit diese die
wärmeabstrahlung der mauer und anderes
jetzt hat auch den windschutz es ist
ganz wichtig weil eigentlich zu können
den starken wind dann plane ich das auf
jeden fall so ein und dann kann ich
ihnen einpflanzen wahrscheinlich erst im
jahr darauf ernten oder dauert es länger
genau man hat bei unserem pflanzen
bereits im ersten jahr vertrag hat man
schon daran die herbst felgen oder
vielleicht auch noch sommer felgen haben
also ein paar fragen sind normalerweise
dran
im zweiten jahr wächst der baum dann
aber sehr stark also wird ganz stark ist
wegen dieses wachstum im zweiten jahr
dann suche ich mir jetzt am besten hier
einen schönen baum aus übernehmen der
mit nach hause genommen werden
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt hier einmal
durchprobiert die fragen und chili
produkte waren wirklich meine favoriten
aus ist alles super lecker und
hedgefonds oder haben uns hier dieses
geschenk paket für euch gegeben und das
könnt ihr gewinnen wenn ihr folgende
frage beantwortet wo befindet sich der
veltenhof in österreich ist rechte
daumen wünsche euch viel glück und dann
gehabt dieses päckchen bald euch ich
pack das jetzt ins auto und dann geht es
bei uns schon wieder weiter vielen dank
die führung war super interessant ich
komme bestimmt wieder vorbei ich habe so
viel gelernt dankeschön alles gute
[Musik]